bueno
[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy recibimos a una eminencia de la
medicina más concretamente de la cirugía
cardiovascular del corazón lleva 40 años
ejerciendo e investigando en francia-
reconocido internacionalmente por ser el
creador del echarpe cardíaco impulsor
del primer corazón artificial biológico
y gran defensor de una medicina para
todos se trata del bio cirujano
argentino del hospital georges pompidou
de parís juan carlos el chad que es
muchísimas gracias y bienvenidos muchas
gracias por la invitación y para poder
hablar con ustedes sobre todo dar un
mensaje sobre que cuáles son los
progresos en la medicina actual y cuál
es el futuro de la posibilidad de la
cardiología cada vez vivimos más tiempo
y las enfermedades cardiovasculares se
han convertido en una de las principales
causas de muerte en el mundo cuando un
corazón ya no funciona se puede
trasplantar otro pero no se puede hacer
de forma
porque no hay siempre corazones
disponibles para todo el mundo que
necesita usted lleva toda la vida
buscando alternativas al trasplante para
curar esos corazones en los años 80
desarrolló una técnica revolucionaria le
charter cardíaco para situarnos un poco
díganos brevemente en qué en qué
consiste esta técnica ahora tratamos de
hacer una técnica que se podría ser
aplicada rápidamente a todo el mundo no
para los países con alta tecnología
haciendo cirugía cardíaca pero
utilizando una parte del cuerpo se llama
eso biomimetismo tratamos de copiar lo
que hace el corazón en el latido
entonces utilizamos un músculo de la
espalda que es el dorsal ancho o gran
dorsal
se usa en cirugía plástica para
reconstruir la región mamaria por
ejemplo viendo a esa experiencia se me
ocurrió a mí en la década del 80
levantar a hacer un colgajo de ese
músculo preservando la parte de
irrigación la arteria la vena y el
nervio también y una vez que está eso de
hecho se colgajo se separa de la espalda
y luego se lo rota hacia el interior del
tórax y se hace una pequeña ventana
sacando la segunda costilla y desde ahí
va hacia el interior y con ese músculo
vamos a cubrir el corazón una especie
del charter y no solamente lo cubrimos
sino que al músculo le ponemos
electrodos y esos electrodos los
electrodos bipolar van a tener un
marcapasos que le va a dar una
estimulación para que produzca un latido
que va a ayudar al latido del corazón es
una asistencia biomecánica y aguantas
cuántas vidas ha salvado con esa técnica
alrededor de 2.000 pacientes en el cual
se interviene nuestro grupo pero se han
hecho en otras partes del mundo que
nosotros
los grupos continuaron de manera
autónoma y todavía se realizan algunos
lugares de asia en europa del este y en
américa latina sobre todo porque no se
utiliza en francia por ejemplo se puede
yo solo utilizamos para ciertas
enfermedades todavía que es la
enfermedad del ventrículo derecho en el
cual no hay medicación lo que pasa que
en la insuficiencia cardíaca que es a la
indicación más insuficiencias cuando el
paciente tiene un grado en el cual no
puede respirar tranquilo le falta el
aire no puede hacer ejercicios y tiene
que estar en reposo para integrarlo a la
vida activa entonces se indica esto y
cuando uno quiere no hace falta un dador
no hay rechazo del músculo del mismo que
va a estar envolviendo el corazón esas
son las grandes ventajas y
económicamente nadie paga nada porque es
un músculo de sí mismo que está
trasladado lo único que se tiene que
comprar es un electrodos y un marcapasos
que también creamos nosotros pero en
estos países han habido el beneficio de
la farmacología nuevos tratamientos de
la insuficiencia cardíaca
hay mucho desarrollo de la medicación
para insuficiencia cardíaca y aparte ha
habido para los pacientes muy graves
asistencias mecánicas pequeñas bombas
que se pueden colocar unas semanas o
unos meses y esperando un trasplante
cardíaco pero siempre hay lugar para
este tipo de técnicas biológicas y ha
habido evolución en esa técnica
con ese charter que ahora se hace de
forma artificial no con la ayuda de
células madres
si nosotros participamos en esa
evolución de la célula madre sabiendo
que tienen un potencial de convertirse
uno la saca de la grasa de la médula
ósea de la del músculo se pueden obtener
células madre progenitoras y esas
células se pueden cultivar y preparar
del mismo paciente o sino también
haciendo un banco de células pero cuando
se inyectaron en infartos se vio que
esas células no crecían no sobrevivía la
mayor parte moría como la agricultura te
pones semillas en la tierra que no es
buena
eso no va a grecia necesita irrigación
necesita necesita nutrientes y eso pasa
en un corazón infartado hay una cicatriz
entonces niños de nosotros avanzamos de
la célula madre hacia la creación de un
tejido artificial la ingeniería de
tejidos muy monos los fundadores de un
grupo internacional y mismo y una
publicación que se llama tissue
engineering en el cual participamos
gente que hacemos no solamente tejido
cardíaco tejido para reemplazar una
tráquea para hacer una vejiga es decir
una pared abdominal ese ese material que
se produce a ver que copiando
el miocardio artificial o lo que uno
quiera porque el desarrollo de las nano
biotecnologías que son menos que un
micrón permite copiar exactamente cómo
es la estructura del músculo uno crea
primero una matriz sexta celular
artificial porosa ahí inyectamos esas
células eso se cultiva unos días in
vitro y luego cuando eso está más o
menos armado el níquel se pone como un
parche sobre la zona infartada o
cubriendo todo el corazón como hacíamos
antes como un echarpe cuando todas estas
técnicas ya no son suficientes para un
corazón enfermo hay que poner un corazón
nuevo
usted justamente es propulsor también
del primer corazón bioartificial desde
el hospital georges pompidou con el
profesor alan capón tiene un corazón con
sensores creados en la industria
aeronáutica cual es la especificidad de
ese corazón que se llama bioartificial
sobre todo el gran problema cuando uno
pone un corazón artificial es que
adentro la sangre no se coagule
hay una tendencia de la sangre a
coagularse sobre todo que está en
presencia de membranas que son
artificiales en plásticos por esa
cavidad artificial entonces lo que nos
utilizamos es
a ese corazón esencial está forrado al
interior por pericardio bovino el
predicar bueno es un tejido animal pero
cuando no lo trata con gluten al debido
como se trata el cuero de un zapato que
no hay más nada del animal de origen
porque es las células se destruyen y se
fijan entonces al tener esa forma al
interior y las válvulas todo eso
biológicas se convierte en un corazón
bioartificial y eso evita que se tenga
que coagular un poco al principio muy
poco pero no muy de anticoagulados
porque una persona que vive anticuado
tiene un pequeño corte en la mano donde
sea puede tener una hemorragia una
hemorragia digestiva digamos el riesgo
es importante y una hemorragia cerebral
en cierto momento la vida que uno tiene
arteriosclerosis así que es un corazón
bioartificial y eso es más que los
sensores yo diría la condición de ser
bioartificial es muy importante a cuánta
gente se le ha implantado este tipo de
corazón y creo que se suspendieron los
ensayos en francia y luego hubo interés
en que sea un programa europeo y luego
internacional
así que todo esto es bueno poder de
trabajar porque hay equipos interesados
en otros países así que se ha hecho en
este momento en dinamarca en república
checa
y también al ser visitante en asia y en
este momento eeuu la autorización para
hacer cuatro casos y free que es el
equivalente al instituto de la salud que
permite que ese material ha sido
considerado como apto para ser probados
en seres humanos este año 2020 podría
ser un año clave para el desarrollo de
ese corazón
bioartificial se podrán volver a hacer
ensayos sobre todo en algunos casos y
también en la república checa y en
dinamarca hay grupos que se están
formando regularmente al hospital propio
vienen una vez cada mes un grupo con
enfermeros anestesistas reanimadores
cirujanos para formarse en la técnica y
luego van y vuelven y las primeras
impresiones son asistidos por nuestro
cirujano y luego siguen como los grandes
solos vamos hacia la construcción de
personas invencibles y mortales con esas
técnicas no aún no no yo creo que no
hace falta que se demostrar porque hay
que ver la realidad mundial también nos
estamos hablando de esta zona del mundo
donde bueno hace poco un estudio
norteamericano que dijeron reduciendo
las calorías y reduciendo la
alimentación se aumenta la sobrevida eso
en eeuu en francia pero si usted reduce
las calorías alimentación en américa
latina en áfrica se van a morir más
rápido porque ya se mueren de problemas
de malnutrición así que yo creo que es
un
un poco de lirio o una ambición de los
países que viven mucho pero hay que
pensar también que porque vivir en con
qué calidad de vida los tejidos del
cerebro no va a aguantar la enfermedad
de alzheimer que es el depósito de una
sustancia amiloide en el cerebro a
cierta edad hay agua y gente más joven
se está descubriendo que también se
puede depositar en el miocardio en el
corazón así que estamos viendo que no se
vive más y hay corazones que se estudian
porque se operan se está viendo que hay
una especie de alzhéimer cardíaco no
solamente cerebral quiere decir que el
cuerpo envejece no se puede digamos se
puede vivir mejor pero para estar toda
la gente sin movilidad porque el aparato
locomotor eso es muy difícil de
conservarlo entonces realmente es decir
yo creo que hay que poner mucho esfuerzo
también financiero y de creatividad en
la infancia en las poblaciones más
nutridas
la infección es la primer causa de
muerte en áfrica en américa latina
todavía justamente usted ha participado
ha llevado a cabo labores humanitarias
en varios puntos del mundo en áfrica
cuál es la aplicación de esas técnicas
en las que usted ha sido pionero en
áfrica se puede hacer echarpes cardíacos
no se puede hacer una depende en lugar
de eso fui director del hospital en
sudan del sur hace unos años y la
primera enfermedad de la gente que venía
al hospital de campaña que instalamos en
el fondo de un gran hospital era el
hambre entonces le preguntamos cuántos y
hace que no convencía el tratamiento era
la comida hacían años que no veían el
azúcar son poblaciones que tienen que
mirar se tienen que ir porque hay
guerras locales religiosas étnicas y
siempre hay dinero para comprar armas
pero a veces no hay dinero para comprar
medicamentos y asistir a la población la
desnutrición es un tema el mundo la
mitad del mundo se muere porque le falta
hambre y la otra mitad porque tiene
exceso tenemos que comenzar tenemos que
con bueno pues nos quedamos con eso
muchísimas gracias
el señor juan carlos chat kers por haber
venido hasta nuestros estudios y les
deseamos muchos éxitos desde el hospital
georges pompidou y muchísimas gracias a
todos ustedes por habernos acompañado ya
saben que nos pueden seguir por internet
en rf y mundo.com france24 puntocom
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]